getting up close and personal a campaign
mast but in a pandemic
Brazil's Jaya Vasa Naru considers
lockdowns excessive a show of strength
[Music]
Britten's Boris Johnson landed in
intensive care with the coronavirus
after shaking patients heads people
who've worked closely with him say he
considers illness a sign of weakness in
February President Donald Trump
announced the disease would just
disappear and it's lucky that you have
this group here right now for this
problem or you wouldn't even have a
country left together the US has the
highest death toll it continues to rise
three world leaders accused of
incompetency and they are all men hi I'm
Ben for zulan women are leading the way
in this crisis there are enough examples
as you'll see in a moment but is this a
revolution of women or are we seeing a
crisis of competency by so many male
leaders around the world I'll be talking
to an expert about that later in the
show
first here's the W's Kate Ferguson on
gender politics clear communication
quick decisive action and a willingness
to listen to science just some of the
accolades these leaders have received
for their handling of the corona virus
and yes they have one thing in common
take Taiwan learning from the SARS
outbreak in 2003 leaders lying when
acted faster than many of her
international counterparts by banning
travel from China early implementing
strict health screenings and increasing
the production of face masks the result
Taiwan has recorded well under 500 cases
so far Australia an island nation with a
similar sized population has more than
ten times that
then there's New Zealand its leader
Jacinda Arden has been pursuing a strict
policy of elimination
the result our transmission rate that is
the number of cases that each person
with the virus passes it on to is now
0.48 listen half a person each oversees
the average is 2.5 people we have
amongst the lowest number of confirmed
cases per 100,000 people in the world
another key feature of a successful
response to the crisis not resting on
your laurels after announcing a
loosening of lockdown measures in
Germany Chancellor Angela Merkel
continued to call for caution bhindi it
sprinkle off him we do not yet know what
the consequences of easing restrictions
will be that's why we have to act step
by step slowly and cautiously for this
dish for game not every female leader is
a good crisis manager I'm not every male
leader is a poor one but early evidence
from this pandemic suggests that being
led by a woman could be good for a
nation's health and its wealth
Jennifer Curtin University of Auckland
your work focuses on women in politics I
don't want to get into a battle of a man
versus woman but tell me are women
better at managing crises like this
pandemic well I think that's the
impression that's certainly being
promulgated through the media at present
but I think part of the reason why we're
seeing this debate happiness because
women remain rather novel as political
leaders preps outside Germany and also
what we're seeing is an increase in the
number of younger women who are taking
leadership at a time when we are seeing
many such a significant crisis so I'm
not I wouldn't necessarily buy into the
argument that women are better at
managing crises it's more that there's
an increased number of women during what
is this exceptional crisis than what
we've seen and
past and therefore a higher percentage
of female leaders who are doing a better
job what can the men learned from the
men well I think part of the reason why
we're seeing women political leaders
doing so well and being reported
positively during this time is because
there are several high profile male
leaders that are taking quite a
contrasting approach to managing this
crisis and so some have reported this as
a more of a rather aggressive
unnecessarily perhaps aggressive
rhetorical approach one that that some
have portrayed as hyper masculine and so
the contrast thin between empathetic
resolute women leaders and perhaps hyper
masculine male leaders is quite extreme
and quite contrasting and so more
noticeable you've pointed out that
experts say women will pay a higher
price due to this pandemic I thought the
fatality rates higher among men I think
it depends on what you're counting as
the impact of the pandemic so yes death
is one of the most severe outcomes that
we're seeing but we're also seeing quite
stringent policy responses in some
countries including lock downs that's
what's happening here in New Zealand in
other countries too and so we know that
when this happens women tend to take up
the majority of caregiving
they are also then expected to work from
home and still manage the children a
majority of health sector workers are
women so there are as there are there
are challenges in the space for women
compared to men could this crisis
help put the spotlight on women and
highlight the extremely important role
they play in society and perhaps even
see more women move into leadership
positions well I certainly think
that the the role modeling effect of
Merkel in this crisis our own Prime
Minister descender I do and and others
as giving a message a symbolic and a
substantive message to younger women
their politics ends and crisis
management is not to be feared but I
also think that the policy
reconstruction that's going to have to
happen in a covert post covert
environment it's gonna it's going to be
challenging for policy makers to rethink
and how they're not just going to
rebuild infrastructure in our case but
also social infrastructure so there is a
real opportunity for policy makers here
to reimagine a different way of of the
economy working that values a lot of the
work that women have done that hasn't
been recognized as valued before
particularly young paid care work that
women have have been undertaking that
certainly propped up GDPs in the past
Jennifer Curtin director at the Public
Policy Institute at the University of
Auckland thank you thank you our science
editor Derek Williams has also been busy
answering questions again your queries
on the coronavirus is what he had to say
is the virus airborne there's a lot of
debate on this question and the short
answer is that at this point we don't
really know the w-h-o continues to say
that the primary ways SARS Cove -
transmits from person to person is via a
larger droplets emitted when someone
sneezes or coughs those are droplets
that don't remain airborne for very long
but can the virus also enter the air and
infect others when someone who has it
simply breathes out as much smaller
droplets that scientists call aerosols
aerosols remain suspended in the air
from much longer than larger droplets do
and and they travel further if we knew
for sure they presented a danger we
would have to make some fundamental
changes to how we're dealing with the
disease but people who work in the field
say proving airborne
mission will be a difficult task and the
scientific evidence so far remains
pretty mixed some studies say airborne
transmission is likely others say it's
less so a number of viruses can remain
in the body even after infection hidden
from the immune system to SARS cough to
do that what you're talking about are
viruses like HIV or ones from the herpes
family after you've been infected with
them they're able to evade the immune
system by entering a latent state though
later in life they can and they do flare
up again they they reactivate after
South Korea recently reported some
patients who recovered from kovat 19 had
subsequently tested positive again for
it experts have been scrambling to
explain why and coronavirus latency and
reactivation is seen as one possible
explanation in general most of the
biologists that I've read seem to think
it's unlikely as corona viruses in
general don't have life cycles that
involve latency and reactivation but
nobody including the w-h-o is ruling out
the idea completely at this point Kenna
steam Sona inactivate SARS Cove - this
was the folk remedy recommended by the
president of Belarus along with drinking
lots of vodka unfortunately though
neither of those remedies works taking a
sauna won't prevent you from getting Co
vat19 and it won't cure you if you have
it
although the virus would be killed by
prolonged exposure to high temperatures
on surfaces your own core body
temperature doesn't really change in the
few minutes that you're in a sauna if it
did you would die so although taking a
sauna might help lighten your mood don't
expect it to offer either prevention or
cure and only do it if you're lucky
enough to have
private sauna at home definitely stay
away from any public facilities at the
moment